ladies and gentlemen Canyon City well
hey there guys excited to see the
minimalist tonight me too
there's always a little bit of me that
wants to be like welcome to a Canyon
City show now we were on the simply
southern tour and this is our last stop
and I've had the the good fortune and
joy of getting to do this tour these
guys so I really can't wait to bring it
home here in Nashville and looking
forward to so I'm gonna play a few tunes
to start this off as a song of mine
called shot
[Music]
I heard it never rains in California
every day just fades and yellow sunsets
[Music]
maybe I should break away and drive the
suspense when it's a good time for me to
wake up
I had to find my way out of a bad dream
[Music]
in the morning I came through the snow
Pablo
[Music]
couldn't see I see
[Music]
I could hear some
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
from the shelves you're almost you
[Music]
you are too miser
you still
deep down it's time
[Music]
it's time to feel
[Music]
say a Happy Endings we leave off it's
always gonna be another battle to fight
if you that story go all the heroes
[Music]
head up from the shoe
you are to Mauser dogs you stay
deep Minister this time
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
it's time to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
your head up from the shadows you're
almost through the night
although you are two miles of dog you
steady
[Music]
[Music]
it's time to feel the light
[Music]
it's time to feel
[Music]
thank you all so much so so my name is
Paul and I make music under the name
Canyon City and I am so so looking
forward to the conversation tonight how
you guys feeling about it we have some
great stuff coming up we're gonna talk
about well I don't want to you know ruin
it's for you guys I like the minimalist
thing but for me so this is the last
stop of the tour and for me this is a
hometown show so I feel a little bit
like the teacher on the field trip it's
like I want you all on your best
behavior now you represent the whole
school
but but anyways so I'm super excited I
won't stand in the way this night but
first here's one that you may recognize
if you're a fan of the minimalist and I
know you are
anybody know where this is going every
little thing you think that you need or
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing is just feeding
and green oh I bet that she'd be fine
without it
[Music]
every little things you gotta have
everything a thing that you got ahead
all that you reach for all that you grab
or a bet that you'd be fine without it
I'll chew
so tears way
[Music]
Oh je
[Music]
every little thing sparkles and shines
every little thing that sparkles and
shines striving you sweet I do mine but
I bet that should be fine
[Music]
so tell me
Oh ji
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if is it a thing you're lusting for been
minimalist ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you ladies and gentlemen Canyon
City they uh their footsteps are so
perfectly minimalist that I didn't even
hear him coming you know it's funny I
always tell Paul I'm like dude I want to
be you when I grow up like this is what
I want to do so awesome thanks for being
here man well we're back in Nashville it
feels like yesterday we were actually
here in these seats and and now it was
actually the beginning of of like a
really difficult period in in my life
that night I started to get really ill I
actually my five year old daughter while
she was four at the time gave me hand
foot and mouth disease which I thought
was something from the 1800's but
apparently adults can get it too and I
we we left here I was totally fine in
Nashville then we flew over to
Washington DC and I couldn't leave my
hotel room and I swear to you the next
three months were three the most
difficult months of my life like those
ups and downs with health and for those
of you who follow our podcasts probably
know I've been dealing with a whole lot
the last two two and a half years with
health but I'm happy to say especially
this month I feel better than I have in
my entire adult life
well thank you and and so I'm grateful
to be back here that last event sold out
really quickly and then you all sold
this out again tonight which is really
great because a hundred percent of the
money that Ryan and I would have made
from this we're just gonna donate to
this charity we're trying to help build
a thank you we're trying to build help
build a a grocery store and one of the
largest food deserts in the country our
hometown is Dayton Ohio
thanks and people there just don't have
access to both the real food they have
access to light the Rito's at the local
liquor store or whatever but but real
food just you know it's the second
hungry city for for families with
children in our country and we want to
help change that so you all made a
difference with that what do you say we
record a podcast tonight beautiful well
let's do it
live from the City Winery theater my
name is Joshua fields Milburn welcome to
the minimalist podcast we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less and I am Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists live in
Nashville Tennessee
ma'am Birmingham a Louisville is gonna
be so jealous when they hear that so we
have a very special guest with us
tonight we might as well go ahead and
dive right into it because we're here
for you all before we jump into it we
got a couple microphones set up
somewhere around here
can someone maybe point me to where they
are they know there's oh there's one
here and there's one here this one is
the money microphone this one is the
minimalism microphone let's talk about
this for a second this microphone if you
have questions about money so that
finances car payments retirement
investing index funds whatever this
guest tonight is really gonna help us
out with a lot of that and if you have
questions about minimalism so letting go
or simplifying or simple living or just
random questions for any of the three
people on the stage that's this
microphone over here we'll get to as
many questions as we can tonight because
we're really here for you all so let's
welcome our guests out to the stage you
may know her as the author of love your
life not theirs
she's also well she has a new show it's
called the Rachel Cruz show ladies and
gentlemen
Rachael Cruz
hello hello we actually found a person
who's from Nashville I know
telling him backstage I was like when
you meet people in Nashville they're
from all over but I'm a local it's good
yes indeed so so we're happy to be here
back back at Tennessee and one of the
things that we often talk about with
folks is we get a lot of questions about
money and it's nice to have you and we
just did a few stops and we did one in
Birmingham one in Louisville with
Anthony O'Neill and and Chris Hogan who
were on the same team as you are and we
get a lot of questions about money and
Ryan and I can only pontificate for so
long about money until we run out of
ideas but it's nice to have some some
experts but you also talked a lot about
comparison and sort of the trap of
comparison and I think money is really
entangled with that and we're I think
one thing that minimalism allows us to
do is sort of simplify so we can remove
that that idea that we need to compare
ourselves what are some of the struggles
you see people deal with now with
respect to money and comparing
themselves to other people well I think
comparison has been around forever but
you go back you know two generations ago
and it was keeping up with the Joneses
right Harrison right and you actually
had to see the Joneses in person right
about 20-30 years ago so it was the the
neighbors you know you actually had to
see them but now because of social media
we carry them around in our back pockets
on our phones and it's this window it's
this picture into everyone's life and we
all know this and we're all probably
guilty of it is that the social media U
is the best-looking coolest funniest
best you out there right because no one
puts a bad picture of themselves or
something boring that's going on right
it's always the highlight reel of their
life and so as a consumer when you're
looking at what other people are doing
you easily can go into this trap of wow
everyone is living this amazing life
like everyone is having the best job
they're getting a raise they're going on
vacation for the fourth time this year
you know you have a new car they have
granite countertops in their kitchen you
know whatever it is
seeing it and the hard reality that we
see from studies and just statistics is
what the average American owes on debts
via credit cards car loans student loans
and what they're making and so 70% of
Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck but that is not 70 percent of
your social posts and so what happens is
we tell this lie to our self that well I
should and I'm speaking your language
now I should expect this standard of
living and if I can't get there with the
money I have I'm gonna go into debt for
it so you know I always say that
comparison doesn't just steal your joy
but it seals your paycheck because you
can spend money and money you don't have
to keep up a lifestyle that you think
everyone else is living and you're the
only one missing out and that's the lie
that comparison tells us and a lot
because of social media yeah it's you
talk a lot about fake rich and how these
comparisons it makes it makes us want to
pretend that we are rich also but what a
world of hurt it can it can definitely
get us in so I guess when it comes to
what what have you learned about fake
rich what what uh what tips do you have
for folks to help them to not want to
live that fake rich lifestyle well when
it comes to comparison or this idea that
you have to keep up this lifestyle and
pretending to be rich it's a heart issue
at the at the bottom of it and
contentment is something that is so
crucial especially when you win when you
want to win with money and it's funny
when I talk to people about money and
whether it's in an interview or I'm
doing an event and there's a question
you know they they want the tactical
aspects of money which is legitimate and
I can totally answer those questions
tonight for sure but there's a heart
issue when it comes to money that a lot
of people don't talk about and it's real
because when you are content what comes
from that is gratitude so when you live
your life being grateful for what you
have and a heart that is filled with
gratitude there is no room for
discontentment and comparisons and so
really getting to this point where you
have peace really with yourself to say
hey you know what I can still strive for
goals I can still strive to get that
next job promotion I can strive for
these things you know having a goal is
not a bad thing but to say in the moment
in the present I'm happy
and I'm content with what I have and so
it goes back to that that's the
foundation that has to be laid because
if you're not if you're not content the
the the shiny new car isn't gonna
magically make you it's not gonna give
you lasting contentment you'll get the
ephemeral pleasure of the purchase but
that that it's it's like having some
sort of cocaine high that doesn't last
past the checkout line usually right it
certainly doesn't last once you get that
first statement in the mail and you have
to start making these $500 a month
payments and so so we have to if we're
not happy with where we are right now
that can be okay it's a signifier that
we need to change but it doesn't mean we
need to add more pacifiers to our life
it means we need to change the behavior
and I think we've all been guilty of
believing this idea oh gosh that thing
it's gonna make me happy and I've said
it before like if I remember being in
college I'll never forget this and I was
in j.crew and I was like you know 19
years old I was like if I could just
have that coat there was a coat and
right and all the expensive stuff in
those stores is right when you walk in
of course right so it's like the best
stuff is right there and I remember
saying that to a friend I would
seriously just be so happy if I could
just get that coat I'll be good and you
know what after a few months I say four
and I bought that coat but that coat the
next winter became something else in my
closet right that newness is gone and
you live like you're a rat in a wheel
your whole life if you think stuff is
going to fulfill you because I promise
it can be fun and you can enjoy stuff
but it will not fill that that void but
your feeling you don't know love about
what you teach - it's very similar to
Josh and I so Josh and I is the
minimalist lake people have never heard
of us they assume that like you walk
into our homes and we own nothing or
like maybe like one chair in one fork
and one spoon per you know family member
in the house but but I'm coming over to
Ryan's now I say Ryan can I borrow the
spoon sorry I already lent it out so so
Josh and I we're not against buying
stuff we all need to consume some things
and and and you like Josh and I you also
like to consume some things you like to
spend money and and I love what you talk
about in your book how it's not about
you can't have these things because some
of these things aren't just you know
it's not a code from j.crew maybe it's a
nice vacation
or maybe it's a nicer home or whatever
it may be some of these things are
totally possible for us to have but I
love how you say like yeah we can have
it all we just can't have it all at once
right and my dad said all the time to us
growing up which I stuck with me said
it's okay to have some nice stuff just
don't let your nice stuff have you and
your stuff hey Jessica tweet that
Jessica but really I mean and your stuff
can have you it can own you when you go
into debt for it because it owns you
don't your paycheck and your contentment
if you're if your identity if your value
is in that thing so you're exactly right
and part of our message too is is we
want you to get out of debt and we say
around our place to live like no one
else you sacrifice you have one fork in
one spoon right like you sell every day
like you sacrifice so you live like no
one else so later you can live and give
like no one else so money is not the bad
point of it but it's a magnifying glass
and it makes you more of what you
already are absolutely yeah that's
beautiful and and so you also wrote a
you co-authored a book smart money smart
kids and I have a five-year-old what
should I be teaching my five-year-old
right now about money and then how do i
how do I because how do i I made a lot
of mistakes in my 20s with money how do
I prevent her from making some of those
same mistakes well just say a little
word of encouragement to that end point
because I think a lot of people and I
have two kids of my own they're still
three and one so they're younger but I
look at them and mistakes I've made you
know whether it's with money or other
things and I'm like you know I want them
to learn those lessons but I so don't
want them to have to go through that
pain and so I really believe you know in
my family's story my parents filed
bankruptcy the year I was born and so I
look at that I'm like that's the worst
of the worst right you're at the bottom
of the bottom and I don't believe I have
to do that to live out good principles
with money you know just gonna go out
and file for bankruptcy so I'll have to
say yeah your dog your kids do not have
to make the mistakes that you've made I
don't believe that so a five-year-old I
mean tactically speaking you don't have
to make it complicated some people like
you know I've been showing her what a
SEP IRA is the difference
well Dave Ramsey's my dad and so people
assume growing up with Dave Ramsey as my
dad is that we had like mutual funds
parties right budget camps all the time
and so yep you don't have to do that by
any means so for a five-year-old I mean
simple I always tell parents to teach
them where money comes from and money
comes from work and so for us growing up
we were never given an allowance we were
always on commission so you work you get
paid you don't work you don't get paid I
love that and it's good because you meet
like 35 year olds who don't know that
right I mean so yeah it's a good lesson
to learn at five so teaching them where
money comes from and then doing three
things with money and even getting three
envelopes and you market give save and
spends and once they earn that money you
do it in that order and whatever
percentage you want you know I'm not
that legalistic so you can just do
whatever percentage that you decide to
as parents but you give something first
you save something second and you can
spend less so you're building really all
three of those money muscles and as
adults if you think about it you know
whether it's investing or whatever
you're doing those are really the three
things you can do with money give save
and spend and so starting that early is
huge because I meet people who can save
and spend like no one else but they're
not givers they live their life like
this or you meet people that that give
everything and spend everything and
they're broke can't afford food right
and so yeah see balancing out all three
of those things and a five role they can
grasp it and that's the encouraging
thing they can get it so I love how you
all encourage to give like that is the
number one thing that you always list
because when you know what when I think
of some of the other programs or things
especially growing up I feel like in the
90s was like that prime time for the
infomercial I will make you it's like
right exactly and and and no one ever
talks about that and you know ultimately
that's what Josh and I that's what we
want to help other people do it is I
mean it truly is our mission it's funny
people all the times like Ryan wears
this minimalist thing going and you know
I mean really I don't know where it's
going but I'll tell you where I wanted
to go no you know ultimately we all we
all need some security we need to feel
some safety for ourselves before we feel
like
we can start giving to other people
absolutely and I think minimalism is a
is a nice tool that helps us to get to
that place where we we can feel like we
have enough we can be content we can be
satisfied and once we have that feeling
then we can start looking outwardly to
our friends family community in
contribution so thank you so much for
for sharing that and making put in
putting that first absolutely because
it's I mean it really is the key to yeah
I mean and and I'm and I'm pretty
hardcore on and so are we like we talked
about when you're doing your budget that
the very first line item is giving and
and I talked to almost eight out of ten
people will say oh great Rachel but you
know if I don't do that I'm not able to
pay X & Y Z because a lot of people are
tight with their budget but I'm like
okay but you're giving Comcast 100 bucks
a month like you know I mean like it's
it's like where are your priorities and
you really have to think about that it's
not always a math issue it's a heart
issue and I love john d rockefeller his
quote is one of my favorites he said it
I never would have been able to tithe
which is give ten percent I never would
have been able to tie the first million
dollars I ever made if I didn't tied my
first salary which is a dollar in fifty
a week and people think all the time if
I just had more money I would give but
I'm telling you if it does not become a
habit in your life it gets harder the
more money you get it absolutely does I
remember being back in the corporate
world it's sort of the apex of what I
earned in the corporate world I was
managing 150 retailed stores and a
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
but I was giving functionally nothing
and and it was because I was out
spending everything that I'm a I made
good money but spent even better money
so I just didn't have it to give because
I hey I didn't budget accordingly but
but B I just felt like I'll get to it
one day if I'm making 200 thousand now I
can definitely give some day if I make
400 thousand that's what the magic
number that you can give but of course
when I walked away from the corporate
world I made about about 90 percent less
of my first year I made $23,000 and I
gave more that year than I did when I
made you a 90 percent more than that and
it's because I made it a priority to do
so and it's still priority for us now
and
and also to encourage other people to
give as well because when you compound
that giving I see that you know that's
when you can really change communities
when you can change people's lives
speaking of people's lives we want to
we're here for you so we have a couple
microphones here let's answer some
questions yo we got money and minimalism
and miscellaneous right here now here's
the thing someone's gonna have to break
the ice and then oh yeah we got a few
all right awesome thank you so much cuz
I just thought I was gonna be like the
minimalist most minimalist podcast ever
howdy
what's your name where you from I'll let
you go on the money side first my name
is Thomas gentry here - I may or may not
have filmed you guys in LA once with
Paul but I may or may not have filmed
you guys in LA once with Canyon City but
I've got a question for Rachel beautiful
so if your salary fluctuates hugely
year-to-year how do you decide I mean do
you feel like it's always 10% or do you
feel like you know if you're freelance
and one year you can make 25,000 another
year you can make 125,000 how do you
budget so that you can also save for the
times that are slower it's a great
question so for your budget I always
recommend people doing a budget every
month and before the month even begins
so it does take some planning so you
know you say okay the next month is here
and so usually it's freelance or I'm on
a most of my stuff is Commission so I'm
totally you're about my my income
month-to-month fluctuates and so what
you have to do is get in a rhythm to say
okay here is what I can plan out that I
know for sure of what I'm gonna make so
you have that number and then what
you're gonna do is you're gonna list
your priorities on your budget docto
we're talking about really are giving a
little giving something saving something
and then what do we call your four walls
so the things you have to have to
survive food shelter and utilities
transportation and clothing and these
are not food you're going out to Kane
prime every night right I mean like this
is hey this is realistic and so you list
those first cuz those have to be taken
care of so that's your priority and then
be
on that it's everything else from
entertainment to to personal
miscellaneous whatever it is is
underneath the rest of that and so as
the money comes in you've already
allotted for your four walls so you put
the cash towards that and then if you
have extra then you can fund the other
categories and if you have a really big
month and you're like oh wow I don't
really need to put these anything else
that's to get in savings and then I'll
roll over and you'll have that nice nest
egg for when the times that do come that
you're like okay I'm it's the 15th and I
still am not getting any work for the
next I'll just pull some from there and
so it takes a lot of intentionality and
it's the one myth I always bust for
people because everyone's like well if
I'm on commission or if my income
fluctuates I can't budget but you can
you just have to be really proactive
with it and it may change and you make
it halfway through the through the month
and say okay I thought I was gonna be
able to spend this but I'm not you know
put it up or down or whatever so yeah
I'll recommend to the Ramsay team has
put together an amazing app called every
dollar and I've been using it for the
last couple months it is it's and the
first thing the first line item on that
app is giving it's like it's it like it
just puts it at the forefront of your
mind but but the budgeting is such an
amazing tool too powerful tool it's it's
something that um why I think you talked
a little bit about how sometimes you
feel like it's limiting but it actually
gives you a lot of power because you
know exactly where your money's going do
you have a budget right now okay that's
okay man Sun a promo no I mean aya so I
was I was on a budget until until I got
out of debt 100% and then I kind of let
the budget go by the wayside and then I
moved to LA so no it's not that bad but
a couple months ago I was like oh wow
like this is this is a lot of work so
that's at the Montana like we need to go
on a budget again and so Mariah and I
have been doing this for the last two
months but it is like the most freeing
rewarding thing and there's something
about it um when you limit yourself to
going out to eat for example like when
you choose those times to go out when
Mariah and I choose a time to go out to
eat like we enjoy that experience so
much more because we know we're gonna
get to do that only a couple times them
so the budget man like that is it is
such a powerful tool I like that you
said to cuz a lot of people assume Oh a
budget they're like oh it's so
restricting and I can't have any fun
like I always thought when I heard the
word budget because it's the hardest
thing for me financially that I had to
like make a habit of my own life because
it was I feel like people you know it
would always say like oh we're not going
out to eat we're on a budget or we can't
go shopping around a budget we can't go
vacation on a budget and people on
budgets are not fun people but what it
realize is it really is permission to
spend it let's your yes be yes with
confidence so you're never at the
grocery store or Trader Joe's or
wherever and you're like oh is that too
much is that okay
it's never a question because you know
exactly where your money's going so
you're telling your money where to go
and that's what about jobs but seriously
every all our the app amen hallelujah
all the way it's the best thing I think
that that sometimes when if we don't
have those constraints than our money
sort of functions like you blow up a
balloon and just let it go you don't
know where it's going to end up and
that's that kind of how how I was for
literally all of my 20s it was just like
I would get the end of the month and be
like oh my god what just happened
right I made all this money I still now
I'm trying to figure out how do I pay my
mortgage still and it's because I just
let the balloon go and it just went
everywhere that's not real freedom real
freedom requires those constraints think
about my five-year-old when you think
about freedom you think about doing
whatever you want whenever you want
right but imagine if I let my
five-year-old do whatever she wanted
whenever she wanted is that freedom no
that's the opposite of freedom she's
going to she's gonna get her she's gonna
throw tantrums if she wants to throw
something across the room because she
gets mad because I'm not gonna let her
watch Peppa Pig
then is that real freedom now real
freedom requires a particular kind of
discipline and so creating whether it's
a budget or finding intentional ways to
give and spend our money with thought
those constraints that we build up I
think yeah that requires the discipline
that most of us have we just choose not
to exercise but if you do exercise it
that's when we experience a real freedom
thanks your questions thank you guys
good to see you again we'll go over to
the the minimalism mic here howdy what
today were you from my name is Andrew
and I'm actually from Virginia but I
just moved here to Nashville in October
and welcome to Tennessee thank you thank
you very much I've been loving it by the
way it's great you know Riya was born in
Tennessee I didn't was born in Knoxville
yeah I yeah we lived in Sevierville
which is like right outside of Pigeon
Forge Gatlinburg man that place does not
look the same
[Laughter]
I want to prefix this by just saying
thank you to you Josh and you Ryan
because I swear to God from day one I've
had a brother my brother Jonathan who I
love very much my parents love me I've
got a really good support system but
from day one because until I didn't
realize it so recently Society I had put
so much pressure on myself to compare
myself to him right he's a licensed
psychologist with a VA and you know he
realized he want to do that when he was
18 years old and I didn't know what I
wanted to do you know my parents come to
me and they're like you know we're gonna
help you through college so what do you
want to do and I'm like and how old were
you at computers I was like 16 17
whatever
hey you're 16 what do you want to do
with the rest of your life Yeah right
right so I jumped right into it and then
you know I didn't really like sitting in
office so I actually got the degree from
them and I said well I'm gonna get into
dentistry because you know that's a lot
of money I swear to God I looked at I
think you said that in the beginning of
podcast you said you looked at a list of
careers that you want to go
it was finance was high and I was like
oh look dentistry is at the top so let
me do dentistry so I picked that and I
went back to school for biology and I
got my biology greeting I'm like I don't
I'm not feeling like the passion for it
so I ran into your documentary on
minimalism sitting in a lab after I
moved here about a month or two months
three months maybe something like that I
don't know
I go and I wash and I was like wow and
it really changed my life and I thought
like you know what I'm not gonna live
for things or you know salary caps I'm
gonna do what I want to do so I started
doing it in this leads to my question I
moved out here in October because you
know my brothers out here my parents are
out here and I started just getting rid
of my stuff cuz I'm like look here's my
opportunity I'm just gonna look at my
stuff this is before I even watched your
documentary I said I'm gonna get rid of
this stuff you know I'm gonna pack
everything in my car mainly because I
didn't want to pay for it u-haul you
know like I'm just gonna put everything
in there and I'm about I thought wow
like I could go wherever I want in the
world with everything I own in my car
that feels great so I just I guess out
of happenstance I run into your
documentary I watched it and I thought
holy smokes this is like a whole thing
I've never even thought about and got
into it so I've just getting gotten
really into minimalism I've been
watching your podcast I tweet you guys
all the time you know and they so
support me
people of course have a question right
yeah yeah oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry sorry so the question is this
actually I've actually gotten really
into it and people are saying why are
you so happy bye brother you know who's
got all this stuff and his wife he's got
all this stuff who I thought should be
where they wanted to be or labeled
what's going on with you like why are
you feeling so free why are you feeling
so happy and they said well I you know I
tell them about minimalism and they say
I don't have a good answer for it they
just say oh I get it you know I told him
to watch the documentary and they say
well just get rid of all your stuff
that's what minimalism is about right
and like
so might be my question is this what is
the cliff note version for you guys when
somebody asks you what what it what does
minimalism about they don't want to hear
it they don't want to hear what's the
magic answer judge yeah well so okay my
my pithy answer to that question tends
to be minimalism is the thing that gets
us past the things so we can make room
for life's most important things which
actually aren't things at all and there
it is
did you write that down we call that a a
quadruple entendre here's the funny
thing about all of this is we have
people will come up to us at events or
they'll reach out to us via email one of
the things people will tell me is like I
remember the time I could fit all of the
my possessions like I was getting ready
to go off to college it fit all in my
car my Jeep and then I just drove off to
college and it was the happiest time of
my life
but now I own all this stuff and I wish
I could get back to that and I just said
well if you thought about getting rid of
that stuff cuz that's how you get back
to it right however that doesn't mean it
translates to everyone right the things
that are appropriate for my life may not
be appropriate for yours I wish there
was a magic list I wish I could pull out
a piece of paper from my pocket that
said well here are the hundred items you
should own if you want to be happy I
mean that would sound really good for
like some sort of a GQ magazine article
or something but the things that I
really enjoy things that add value to my
life that amplify my life that enhance
my experience of life those work for me
in fact they work for me right now at
age 37 when I first stumbled across
minimalism I didn't have a kid I didn't
have my partner Rebecca and I was a
single guide just to gotten out of a
marriage and so my life looked
appreciably different from what it looks
like now and so ultimately minimalism
allows
to continue the question the things I
hold on to let go of them if I'm not
getting value from from those things and
also bring new things into my life more
intentionally because if I not
intentional about the things I bring
into my life then I'll just end up
exactly where I was before a massing
hordes of useless things that get in the
way of a more meaningful life I'm
thinking like when I first started
talking about minimalism like my mom
called me up and she's like hey it's
this minimalist crap like she must have
been googling my name and like it was
like it the first month we launched the
site and I hadn't told anyone so she
must have been like looking me out and I
remember explaining to her that
minimalism was a lifestyle that was
gonna help me change my priorities and
to even condense that more I would say
minimalism for me it is freedom for me
and to say that I mean it the minimalism
is freedom I mean it sounds really good
right but you got to show it and and and
that is really what it comes down to
with I don't know where he went but his
but your brother you have to show him
how minimalism is freedom for you so
with my mom actually with a lot of my
relatives and friends I think the worst
and man I hope he's not listening to
this but my uncle if you are listening
to this I love yunk you know it but uh
but he gave me probably the most crap
for the longest period of time and when
I say for the longest period of time
Josh and I we sort of the website
December 2010 he came up to me last
October October of 2017 so almost seven
years later he came up to me and I was
just like expecting him to come up to me
and be like he's still a minimalist
you got a snowboard you're not a
minimalist you you got a mountain bike a
minimalist and he'd really talks like
that cuz a horse fell on his chest when
he was a teenager
so it collapsed lung so he really does
have this really really really strange
voice so I would I was expecting him to
come up to me and you know gave me some
kind of crap for you fly here on a paint
a plane you're not a minimalist but it
came up to me and he's like Ryan he's
like no seriously he was like I'm so
proud of you man he was like you know it
I have really seen how not only you've
changed your life but how other people
are reacting to what you're doing he's
like now I see what you're doing he's
like now I understand what you're what
you're doing with this minimalist saying
and he's like I could not be more proud
of you and it took seven years of me
living the example of not telling him to
just f off every time that he was going
to be you know a line it took a lot of
patience it took a lot of me going out
of my way to support him whenever I had
the opportunity to not to say that I
didn't distance myself a little bit cuz
I can only get you know trolled so much
before I start to get angry but but but
but I I went out of my way I did not you
know judge him I didn't I didn't make
fun of his possessions I never you know
snapped back at him um seven years it
took I don't think it's gonna take seven
years for your brother to see how
minimalism is helping your life but uh
it might take some time because again
you can't just say a magic bullet
sentence or a magic line that's gonna
make someone automatically understand
why minimalism is freedom
[Applause]
let's go let's go back to the money
microphone we'll do a few few more money
questions here and actually we'll do one
more money question then we're going to
lightning round don't worry we're gonna
get ever how many people we have here
right now in line we got three of you
here we have how many are in this line
you're all on line
oh good luck we're gonna be here all
night
well do our best so we have how many in
this line via 3d okay three well
definitely we'll do the let's do these
money questions here and then we'll do
our best to get to as many of these
minimalism questions we can well we'll
get through them but whoever's here now
will just stay with that group and not
add any more people because yeah because
we're minimalist don't worry we got
plenty of time right now I just know how
long winded I am what's your name
brother
where're you from what's up man my name
is Dustin Dixon I'm from Orlando Florida
but I just move to Tennessee a month ago
what's your question does it well first
I want to say thank you guys for your
parenting podcast recently because my
parents just came in from when I moved
and they saw how much stuff I owned and
they roasted me so thank you guys that
helped me get through it but my question
is my girlfriend and I live together and
we have separate incomes and I was kind
of curious if you hadn't get advice
about differentiating with separate
incomes groceries date night between
just going out to get food no together
and other important things and still
being able to manage your money and have
a healthy relationship and not kill each
other right yeah so when you're not
legally married you keep everything
separate so do not combine accounts and
I even go so far as to say don't even
like if you start paying off debt don't
put your money towards her paying off
her debts
don't let her pay your debt keep
everything separate cuz what ends up
happening is if the break-up happens
hopefully it doesn't please you guys get
married and wedding bells all the above
but I've talked to so many people who
they combined their finances before
they're married the break-up happens and
they spent tens of thousands of dollars
helping this person that now is not even
in their life right so keeping it
separate 100% however you guys choose to
split the bills
whatever I mean that's kind of you
your your prerogative but money-wise
keeping it separate and then even
through engagement and then once you get
married then you combine accounts you
you know as soon as you say I do you can
just combine those accounts right you
become one and every Hospital points so
that's what I always encourage people
because you have to know though going
into this that money is the leading
cause of divorce in America today so it
is a huge pain point for people in
marriage people that disagree with money
what ends up happening is that they
disagree with their values their goals
their fears their dreams all of that and
so so I would say in the season of you
guys hopefully progressing towards
marriage to say okay we're gonna have
these conversations and get on the same
page about hey when we do get married
one day these are gonna be our shared
values and our shared goals and getting
on the same page early and I took that
to any couple that's dating just that
you have to be aware that obviously not
on the first date you're not gonna ask
like text records and stuff of them
right like you're normal but as the
relationship progresses so should those
conversations for sure so keep that in
the back of your mind that it's a huge
pain point for people and so don't
ignore it by any means embrace those
conversations for sure yeah I mean
Mariah and I like what we will sit down
and do the budget together and it's it's
awesome like being able to talk with her
what our plans are for the month and
again it gives us things to look forward
to but getting on the same page and
supporting one another that's that's
really the key step is making sure that
you both are heading in the same
direction pace your question thank you
[Applause]
alright Ryan you know what time it is
it's time for the minimalists lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media so everyone get out your
cell phones them I'm kidding don't do
that yeah just ignore us and start
scrolling through Twitter no we usually
answer questions of social media we're
at the minimalists on Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram if you want to
ask those questions over there but today
since y'all are here so I'm gonna
explain to Rachel how this works we
usually have a week to prepare a really
nice pithy answer it's 140 characters we
give it to people you know that Jessica
wherever she is she can she can tweet it
Jessica you around here somewhere just
go in William hiding in the back he's
the woman behind the curtain she live
tweets from all of our events and she
makes her social media look pretty and
her main job is to tolerate me most of
the time and so what we'll really do is
we'll get their question what does
ramble on a bit and then eventually
we'll find something that's heavy enough
that we could maybe tweet at the end of
this
howdy with today were you from thanks
we're excited
thank you guys for being here I've seen
you in your dad several times it's the
first love event with you guys my
question is actually a combination of
both in our family we have a tendency to
overthink and worry about a lot of
things so we're in the process of
hanging down a lot of debt and at the
same time we've realized a lot of our
stress comes from the fact that we have
too much stuff so we're doing our best
to get rid of a lot of stuff so you know
following Dave Ramsey in y'all's side
you know we're selling as much as we can
but we tend to obsess and then I guess
the point where we get so stressed out
trying to sell stuff that we just shut
down and were like we don't know what to
do would you just give it all the way so
I guess our question is how do you kind
of balance wanting to get rid of
everything and calming down life to
really being hardcore selling stuff
paying off working extra hard you know
cuz both of us our moms you know we have
jobs I own my own business so to do too
much overwhelms us you know to get to
that financially stable point but then
to do nothing
you know is obviously not really great
so how do you kind of find a nice
balance to both get you know push to get
to that financially stable point but
also not completely stress yourself out
with the amount of stuff that you're
doing in the process sure I would say
when you're in the process of getting
out of debt the deeper you sacrifice the
faster the progress is gonna happen and
so the more you say and it's just a
season you have kids you say your mom -
okay so the mom guilt is a real thing
and so it comes in and these seasons
really if I'm gonna work overtime that
means I'm not putting my kids to bed at
nights right and so a lot of that plays
into the emotions and so I want you to
know that this is for a season you're
not gonna be doing this for the next 20
years you might be doing this for the
next nine months and that might be it
right or the next 12 months but it's not
gonna be your life and so for a short
period of time the more you can
sacrifice the more progress you're going
to see and so that would be one
encouragement and yeah if you walk into
your home and you're like I don't even
know where to start and then you just
start shutting down and you just end up
on a ball on the floor right because
your Linux just start just start
somewhere just taking that next step and
I find that with a lot of people and a
lot of people start out starting to
manage their money well and they haven't
looked at bills they haven't looked at
their income statement they have no idea
anything about their financial life it
is so overwhelming but I always say take
that first step and it's amazing when
you start just even writing things down
like maybe you say okay this week we're
gonna sell three things and you just
write it on a sheet of paper and you
just leave it and that's it and that's
all you have to focus on because again
if it's this black hole of stuff that
you're like I don't even know where to
begin
it's gonna be tough to get started so
find a couple of things at first and
then as you start doing it whether it's
Craigslist or Ebay and you guys are
probably pros don't like how to get rid
of everything but like but really like
you know how to do it so like it's in
the sense that yeah you you're gonna
start to see okay you're uncomfortable
with the process because it's not new
anymore you've already done it
and then suddenly you like okay we can
sell five things next week we can sell
ten things right and you can start
upping that but it's just because it's
new is what's frightening but the when
you do it once you're gonna get your
feet on you're gonna say okay I
understand how the process works she
actually started with her tweet oh boy
answer I'm sure Jess got that about the
more you sacrifice yeah the quicker you
will get this oh so that that's
beautiful I could I can't tell you
what you should do what your specific
parameters are but I could tell you
without boundaries you'll get nowhere
and and and what I mean by that is I had
to put some boundaries on my the things
I was gonna sell because I was also
overwhelmed the average American
household has more than 300 thousand
items in it that's average so late
that's not a hoarders house that's just
like everyone's house has a bunch of
stuff in it and it's not me going around
counting other people's things that's
the Los Angeles Times and so what I
could tell you is for me we're not
because I was both trying to simplify my
life and get out of that at the same
time I put a number on it it was mine
was a relatively low number if I could
sell something for $20 or more I would
sell it if it was less than $20 I found
a way to get rid of it right away and so
I recommend a few things one is is
everything you own fits in one of three
piles guaranteed if it's in one two
three pause it's essential it's those
four the four walls that you talked
about it's sort of something you truly
need in your life right most of us need
food shelter clothing etc right and so
we have these essentials then we have
the non essentials in our life that's
the second bucket those are things that
don't we don't necessarily need but
they'd add value to our lives they
enhance our lives and make life a little
bit better right ideally that's the that
those are the things that most of us
should own the most of the things
enhance our life to make life better
the third category however is what most
of us own that's junk we pretend it adds
value to our lives it has a theoretical
value there's a ton of aspirational
value in these things you bought that
outfit because it looked really good on
the mannequin but then in your closet
every time you've tried it on you're
like ah maybe next time and so it just
sits there in the the walk-in closet
full of clothes you don't enjoy wearing
it's junk it doesn't mean someone else
can't get value from it in fact they can
and they will if you let go of it so if
you can get twenty bucks for it I say
sell it if you can't get 20 bucks for I
say get rid of it really quickly get it
out of the way because it's overwhelming
to you and then set a parameter if you
can't get rid of it this week or this
month for me it was 30 days
so you can get really aggressive and say
this week for me if I couldn't get rid
of it in 30 days sell it then I would
either lower the price to as low as I
could 20 bucks or I would just get rid
of it right now that's even for a big
electronic thing you know if it's a TV
that I thought was worth a thousand
dollars but no TVs are actually worth a
thousand dollars that just happens to be
what I paid for it maybe I can get rid
of this damn thing for twenty dollars
get it out of my life and make some
money to pay down the debts but they
don't get the things out of my life it
allow you to bring in some money and it
allow you to stop you know this is this
sort of psychological torture that
you're putting yourself through yeah oh
it's I would say like when it comes to
selling this stuff this used to drive me
crazy because of the BlackBerry that I
had that was worth five hundred dollars
when I first got it and somehow I you
know I want to get five hundred dollars
back out of that thing when I know I
never will so when it comes to letting
stuff ago you got to get really
comfortable with with two words and that
is sunk cost you really have to
understand that a lot of this stuff
you're not gonna get what you originally
paid for it in fact you might not get
anything for it and that's okay because
when you become comfortable when I
became comfortable with sunk cost it was
so much easier for me to you know take
something that has been sitting on
Craigslist for twenty dollars that's
been sitting there for you know a month
or so I can look at that and say you
know what probably not gonna get
anything out of that that is a sunk cost
I have to let go of the other thing - oh
say is when you're doing this you can
overdo anything you can overdo
minimalism you can overdo budgeting I
think really what it comes down to is do
not forsake your values and beliefs and
now I know that there are some
compromises there might be some late
nights where maybe you're coming home a
little bit later than you would like to
spend with your kids but there is a
balance between some sacrifices and
killing puppies I mean there's there is
a middle ground well I mean I know
that's an extreme example but but I mean
that is obviously something none of us
in this room would ever do if that if
that was getting us out of debt you know
in the next six months of none of us
right so really my short answer is is
don't kill puppies thank you all three
of you guys are a blessing to a lot of
people thank you so much thank you so
much thank you
or do we have any more money questions
here all right we got no all right sweet
well I think we'll move over to the
other microphone here in a second
actually let's do this now because we
got one more lightning round question
let's do this
all right howdy what's your name hi my
name is Vanessa from Chicago well thank
you for being here thanks I'm here with
my aunt and we're a huge day of Ramsey
fans um there's my thank you Rachel like
your book you we're huge Dave Ramsey
fans too also a huge Rachel fans yeah I
like them a lot and actually I got into
minimalism because of Dave Ramsey and I
just feel like they complement each
other very well
and um my aunt did her debt-free screen
today so that yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I just want um to know what you guys
would tell people who think that it's
almost impossible to get out of that
girl's microphone I was looking to you
because I'm like Rachel what how could
we go joke work I would say oh and I'm
gonna butcher the quotes if you think
you can or you think you can't you're
right and so when you're in a state of
hopelessness which is what a lot of
people are when they answer that
question and it's really sad to me
because when it comes to money there's a
lot of hopelessness in this subject for
people because they're living paycheck
to paycheck they're doing the best they
can it's just it just doesn't keep
working what they're doing and so you
have to stop doing what you've been
doing to get something different and so
if you stay in the cycle of just living
credit card bill to credit card bill you
know student loan Sallie Mae is just my
BFF and she's gonna be with me for the
next 20 years so I'll just pay the
minimum payment right if you stay in
this cycle then that's what you're gonna
get you're gonna keep getting that same
result and that's what I think AAA says
is that if you keep doing the same thing
or no is it insanity right if you keep
doing the same thing over over again
expecting different results that's the
definition of insanity and so do you
have to do something different but doing
something different and changing is so
hard for us it's so hard because we're
so comfortable like when we're doing
something even that's wrong like my
husband I we were driving and I was like
babe get off this exit he's like no no
no I'm like no you can eke out that's
what Google Maps is saying is like it's
fine it's fine I was like you're going
the wrong way like I don't care like
this is fine right I mean it's just like
like it's so hard to change its the way
I've been always going and so so you
just have to say I have to change but
change is so hard but if you want a
different result is what you have to do
and that's why we say to getting out of
debt we do the debt snowball where you
list all your debts smallest to largest
regardless of the interest rate and you
pay minimum payments on everything and
you attack the smallest debt first and
what that does is it inserts hope
because even if it's a $300 you
Macy's card if you think you can never
do it but you see that one card that you
haven't seen in you know four years and
you're late on it all of that be like
okay I'm gonna just write a check and
pay it off and it's paid off it's like
oh wow I can do this this is possible
and then you start working that way and
so we have found that personal finance
it's about 80% behavior it's only 20%
head knowledge we know what to do we
just have to change our behavior the
book of it and that's why I listing it
smallest to largest so so I would say
that's it I mean hope is the number one
thing you have to have hope that things
are gonna be different and your actions
have to inflate that yeah I think it's
[Applause]
you Congrats yeah that is yeah
congratulations again that is awesome
when it comes to getting ourselves out
of debt and being a hundred percent debt
free it sounds really scary
it sounds really hard and it is it's
scary and it's really really hard it
takes a lot of hard work I guess if I
was like my short answer would be to get
out of debt one must accept that it's
not easy it takes a lot of hard work and
you must have a plan and those are three
very important things to accept and to
also have if you come up with a plan and
you work that plan there is the ramsey
team has got some amazing plans out
there that you can that anyone out there
can totally mimic these plants and they
work but you do have to work the plan
but accepting because that's a lot of
the time for me I know it's it's
accepting that's something that I really
want to accomplish that's really big
that it isn't going to come easy and
once I can get past that feeling of
shying away from the hard work and I can
kind of lean into it that's where you
start to get the momentum and you start
to build more hope My partner and I were
walking across this bridge we're going
to the gulch is that the place yeah yeah
we were looking for mediocre food and we
found it
[Laughter]
no I won't point out the restaurant it's
not it's not national obviously you eat
the food here it's freaking fantastic at
the City Winery but uh but we were
walking and I'm looking at my phone
we're supposed to turn left on the
street and like we're just having a
conversation walking down the street
today it was very similar to the exit
ramp thing but we were but we just
weren't paying attention and we walked
way too far missed our turn we're just
having a good time enjoying each other
and I said look I'm like hold on let me
check the phone guy see the street and
my first inclination I saw it like wee
wee Bentley passed it like half a mile
ago easy maybe a mile ago we've just
been walking and my first inclination
was like well May if we keep going then
we'll get where we want to go and then
thankfully Beck's was there she's like
hey we have to turn around and like to
me that's the best device because what
happens is we get in this system Brian
talked about having a plan but we often
in our lives set up the system and we
just keep going with that system and
even when it's not working and it's
getting us farther from where we want to
be this is what I've always done so I'm
gonna keep going and so sometimes the
best thing to do is just just turn
around
Thanks your question
[Applause]
all right one second here um if you're
listening to this at home and you have a
question for the minimalists or you have
a comment about anything that we're
talking about today you can give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine or send a voice memo
right from your phone to podcast at the
minimalists comm and it's my favorite
part of the show including the end of
this show we are our listeners comments
and tips we just pick out some favorite
comments and tips and then in future
weeks Ryan and I just really and pretend
they're our answers but we make this
podcast a hundred percent advertisement
free which means it's a hundred percent
listener supported so what we tend to do
every week is we do a PostScript episode
at the end of our podcast and it's
actually it comes up the day after our
normal podcast you can listen to it in
our pot in your whatever podcast player
you you use to listen to podcast and
it's only for our patreon supporters so
if you want to support us help keep the
podcast 100% advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support and you can support us in
that way we won't have any ads but you
will get a whole bunch of bonuses
monthly live streams of ask the
minimalist anything Q&A sessions and so
right now what I'd like to do is
whatever questions we have right now or
right here in this line we will do a
patreon bonus episode a postscript
episode in front of all of you people if
you're cool with that beautiful
[Music]
it's not about giving back to us it's
about paying it forward to someone else
there are a lot of people who have
inspired me whether it's someone like
Rachel or Dave Ramsey or authors who
aren't even alive right now who I've
gotten immense value from from their
work as opposed to me trying to I mean I
couldn't possibly you know what am I
gonna do say hey Dave Ramsey here's a
here's a $400 check for you because you
really helped me out thank you
no I mean and so instead what I try to
do when I get value from other people's
I try to pay it forward to other people
and and that means if there's someone
you can help if it's just one person if
you're helping solve other people's
problems and that's how you how you pay
it forward we've never had someone from
the audience come onstage and overcome
their fear by playing a a song in front
of a sold-out crowd in a major US city
[Applause]
I want to move on to a segment we call
right here right now with where we talk
about what's going on the lives of the
minimalist we're doing this backwards we
will get to added value in a moment but
we talk about what's going on lives in
the minimalist I opened up this talking
about a hundred percent of the profits
from tonight's event actually from this
entire simply southern tour thanks to
the today of Ramsey's team the Ramsey
solutions team you all provided the
talent to allow us to go on the road
between Rachel and Anthony and and Chris
coming on the road with us we're able to
raise a lot of money Ryan and I are also
donated $20,000 of our own money and
we're leaning on our audience to help oh
thanks really people like you were gonna
make it happen I mean it's awesome that
Josh and I could give some money but you
guys really are what make it happen yeah
and this actually the part where I lean
on the audience if you're listening to
this at home or if you all have any
extra money you want to donate you can
go to the minimalists comm slash dayton
we're gonna open up a grocery store and
one of the largest food deserts in the
country and thanks to you all for for
making that happen we're really grateful
also right here right now we're working
on a whole lot more short form video
creation so stay tuned to our youtube
channel youtube.com slash the
minimalists thanks to Jordan he's gonna
be filming all kinds of he's been
filming us on the road we're doing a
video version of the podcast as you can
see as we're filming all of this
including the crazy song and everything
else that just happened tonight and so
we're gonna be doing more video essays
living room conversations the fact we
record the living room conversation
backstage with with Rachel just moments
ago and so stay tuned to our YouTube
channel for a lot more meaningful
in-depth creations not content and let's
move on to right here right now so we
I'm sorry I had it value segment what's
been adding value to your life recently
Ryan so many things did you hear that
song by Austin that was pretty good
oh man uh yeah god that was incredible
um every dollar I've already I already
talked about that if you don't have a
budget if you have money problems
and you don't have a budget stop talking
about your money problems until you come
up with a budget I I'm just I'm just
giving it to you straight and every
dollar is a great budgeting tool of
course love your life not theirs by
Rachael Cruz it is an amazing book just
so much awesome philosophy in there
about not just comparing yourself to the
Joneses but how to use social media how
to budget how to talk to your partner
about it I mean just a very very awesome
book on finances and then some local
stuff man uh of course like resupport
parlor that's pretty awesome
yeah crema you guys go to Chrome middle
premise awesome crema is the first
coffee shop that Josh and I went to when
we did our very first horror so it was
the first coffee shop we went to when I
was on tour when I was like oh like this
is what coffee can be and it really
liked crema has a lot of a lot of
influence on what I mean now Josh and I
we we have a coffee shop and and it was
because of experiences like what they
create that really helped me love coffee
so if you haven't been to crema and you
like coffee I'm sure everyone hears like
why are you talking about crema we know
about crema but if you listen this at
home when you're visiting Nashville
Kodachrome it is freaking awesome yes
indeed I would encourage you to check
out Rachel Cruz's new show it's very
complicated title it's called the Rachel
Cruz show it's easy to remember and I'm
grateful and we're gonna be on episode
we're gonna film one later this week I
don't know exactly when I'll be out but
you can check it out on on her YouTube
channel it's just youtube.com slash
Rachel Cruz you can find all the
information over there and one other
thing that's added value to my life
we've doing this short tour this is our
ninth tour in eight years
thanks we we did we did 50 cities last
year and I said hey why don't we do
three cities this year and so we came to
the south in the summer because that's
what you do in the summer and I asked
our favorite musician to open up for us
and I mean I've Paul Canyon City his his
album that came out last year called
consolation is absolute
my my favorite album of 2017 every song
is meaningful it's beautifully written
and I could talk about it all day but it
wouldn't do it justice so I'd like to
bring him out here to play my favorite
song from that album oh man well thank
you so much Josh and uh guys so I know I
knew I knew you're gonna have to retune
that sorry dude but no please tell
everyone how awesome Josh and I are
while you're tuning going we'll see that
way did you bring the list I printed out
for you the this is phonics this is this
is kind of full circle so our
relationship sort of started here in a
way yeah and alley out back up what's
that like
you know take it how you want to but uh
so I put out put out that record and and
Josh was so kind to tweet about it and I
responded and he he's like Amy well
we're gonna be in Nashville if you want
a ticket and my friends i had
legitimately like a month before any US
happened to already bought tickets to
the show here and so it was really this
for me my friendship with these guys
really started as just fandom of what
they were doing and then had the very
good fortune of getting to hang out with
them and get to know them a bit more and
do some of these shows together and let
me tell these guys absolutely practice
what they preach and they're also just
some of the best people that you'll
you'll run into so it's really I I can I
can wholeheartedly I I really get behind
what they're saying I think it ripples
into the world I think ripples in the
universe but also they're just like
fantastic human beings so they deserve
every every bit of Josh he read
everything on that list Oh some good
work Paul no I was I was telling Rachel
earlier I'm like when so like for
example with Rachel or with Paul Josh
and I have looked up to both of these
people for so long
role models I mean seriously like I want
to be Paul when I want to be that good
at guitar when I grow up I wanna be that
good of a writer it's it's such a it's
such a it's just such a weird thing when
you meet someone you look up to and then
they look up to you back it's it's very
it makes it's just really interesting
we're just complementing each other you
know 24 but that's I mean series I was
telling them backstage don't even share
it here is I was flipping through
Netflix randomly probably a year and a
half ago and I saw this the minimal
second choice like I've kind of heard
about this I'll watch it I watched it I
came into work the next day we're having
content meeting and I just started like
ranting I mean Ranse I was like this
documentary last night was so good we
have so much crap in our lives you guys
and we're at the business at getting
people out of debt I was like so
hardcore they were like taking notes
like okay okay like we gotta get them on
the show if we do it
a little while and then we got connected
and they said yes like a Mentalist said
yes I was like oh my gosh they did so I
was like a fan of them and they asked me
to do this so it is it's like a total a
total circle we appreciate you guys for
us
well I appreciate you guys letting me
fly around in your private jet on this
shut up hey one more round of applause
for Austin was that kid great
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so so Paul this song you're about to
sing is like every time I hear it like I
turn it on it reminds me of home and I
don't know why because you're not from
Dayton Ohio you're from the Midwest
originally but live here in Nashville
now but like I don't know the the words
that you use don't describe the feelings
that I have but the way that you sing it
does so this is a song called find you
oh thank you so much Josh
I'm not gonna follow up that I'm just
gonna play it get a room
[Music]
lately we've been trying to read through
the lines
[Music]
the bars between us
singer holding two
I had this dream couldn't reach through
the fire
[Music]
I pray for downpours rain and lightning
to strike down
[Music]
be storm in the shelter
[Music]
Oh
let's sleep city in my fields all steel
my god through his all these slow down
all our
to party again
[Music]
theythey weed
Stephen demons in the eye
[Music]
made a heaven
passed on
[Music]
just be honest
hi
[Music]
come on watch this train
[Music]
then blow by B leaves at you and all
feeling it coming home all keep
everything
oh let's the city and life behind all
steel right God who is all these minutes
slow down all
I used to find you again
is to fry
[Music]
Tom watching stars by the moon hardly it
stops as it shines on all keep
everything
let's leave the city and life because
all students moonlight to guide throughs
all these then it slowed down Oh
- cried again
thank you so much thank you to the
minimalists
city I'll give you a hug backstage
alright job before we before we wrap
this up I just wanna thank you for being
here tonight
I won't ever take this for granted Ryan
and I started doing this almost eight
years ago we went on our first tour
seven years ago and it was just me and
and Ryan and his Toyota Corolla the same
one he has today and and and we would go
from city to city with a trunk full of
books and sometimes two people would
show up in Knoxville actually our fourth
city two people showed up actually no
one showed up and we waited around 15
minutes and as we were leaving the
coffee shop that we were having our tour
stopped and we didn't even tell them we
were showing up by the way we just now
announced it on our website and we were
leaving and two people walked in and
said hey you're the minimalist right yes
we are so it was really like a
one-on-one session we had for a couple
hours but I learned so much from from
these events and there were night
slavery didn't sell enough books on the
road then we just left in Ryan's car or
if we got lucky we slept on the floor of
a readers you know a house or something
and to be able to come out to do an
event like this we you all pay and that
money goes somewhere meaningful and we
have this meaningful experience together
I feel like we get to exchange something
that we don't get exchanged by just you
know getting into a podcast studio
stuffs great writing books is phenomenal
I love doing it doing a blog doing all
the stuff we get to do but this is
special and I'm really grateful II
decided to spend this evening with all
of us I also want to acknowledge Rachel
I think
well you and your team are doing is so
important you're adding value to to so
many people's lives and you you're
making the world a better place and I'm
grateful for that
thank you so much thank you very much
and I think Ryan whoa dude we're trying
to close it out here are you finished
one thing Ryan for Evan great hair Oh
keep going oh man
what about City Winery let's thank them
for being here tonight all right she'll
if you leave here tonight with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works they show Nast oh thank you
[Applause]
hi minimalists this is martin from
estonia and i have a comment on the city
podcast I want to introduce a website
called teleport org which people can use
to find cities that suit their personal
preferences so basically you just enter
your budget and your wishes about
housing living costs job market travel
connectivity traffic healthcare
pollution tax tolerance outdoors little
everything is there and they will show
you a list of cities all over the world
that you might consider checking out
eating's Josh and Ryan from New
Brunswick Canada listening to your
parents podcast a quotation came to mind
that I thought you and the listeners
would enjoy is your biological family is
not necessarily your logical family I
just thought that would help the
listeners take care
hey Josh and Ryan this is Ethan from
Denver Colorado I just want to send a
message that I think a lot of us who are
on our journeys of self-improvement and
and minimalism are putting a little bit
too much pressure on ourselves to get it
right to get down to the right amount of
stuff or to get to that point where we
finally feel like we've done enough I
just think that a lot of the times it
comes it just comes down to slowing down
and taking a deep breath and and being
able to just say you know what this is
good enough for right now I've reached a
point that is good enough I am good
enough my life is good enough and
sometimes it's recognizing that even
though minimalism is a endless journey
of self-improvement part of that is
taking the time to just say you know
what I'm proud of myself for the work
I've done and I can relax and stop keep
trying to put so much pressure on myself
to to be the perfect minimalist sorta to
get get everything right and minimus